let's talk about who he's going to be
facing next how about that let's talk
about who he's going to be facing next
so we have a story here we have a story
here
who uh uh somebody who didn't say nice
things about uh governor desantis what
what page is that story on by the way
nicki friday yeah nicki free is it page
two okay let's go through uh
uh uh they go page two okay so uh uh
desantis democrat challenger compares
them to hitler in a lot of ways this is
yahoo news story florida agriculture
commissioner democratic cooper guber
notorious candidate nikki fried sat down
for an interview friday and compared for
the governor uh ron desantis to nazi
leader adolf hitler instead of
listening and trying to govern with the
people he is trying to govern over
people and you know that i'm sorry i'm a
student of history too i saw the rise of
hitler freed 42 told podcast co-hosts
melissa ross on florida's public radio
on friday regarding florida's governor
desantis when ron asked freed if she was
making a direct comparison between the
santas and hitler the agriculture
criminal said in a lot of ways yes i've
studied hitler and how he got to power
you know wanting his own militia free to
explain referencing the santa's move to
re-establish a state guard with 22 other
states also utilized in case of
emergency the reason why this governor
wants it is different than the other
states that have been utilizing it for
emergency purposes the governor is doing
it for the sole purpose of power and
doing so makes fear and blaming certain
parts of society and culture and that's
exactly what hitler did to the jews back
in world war ii so when you hear
comments like this being said and then
your comments back in this article is
nicki freed's claim that governor
desantis is a modern-day hitler's as
offensive as it is absurd with the
hysterical comparison free not only
smears millions of floridians as nazis
but also trivializes hitler's crime
against humanity what do you have to say
about nikki frida as a competitor as an
opponent look i mean she's not serious
anyone who could say something like that
number one she's 44 years old she didn't
see the rise of hitler and it's
offensive because actually there are
some people in florida who are holocaust
survivors who did see the rise of hitler
who did experience
these atrocities that she and i and us
we cannot imagine that and so when she
comes out and tries to compare our
governor
to hitler it just it's sick it's
offensive um a number of jewish
organizations came out
and explained why it's offensive um i
kind of touched on it in my quote but
like at the end of the day that is an
inappropriate comparison whether you're
a republican or a democrat whether you
can disagree with somebody without
taking that step particularly because
like the way she explains it about the
state guard
um
as the reporter said to her 22 other
states have this california has it new
york has it states where there are
natural disasters that are very prone to
natural disasters like florida can
really benefit from it because
essentially it just helps with the
national guard um right now florida
national guard is deployed to ukraine of
all places they're called up on a
federal mission because national guard
can also like they're actually on
federal missions more than they're on
state missions so in a state like
florida where we get hurricanes and we
get natural disasters we could use that
extra force that extra team of
volunteers who are trained to respond to
emergencies and to compare that to the
gestapo i mean that is sick it's
offensive
to people who actually went through it
and it's offensive to those who are just
trying to help their state today you
know so i i don't think people take
nicki freed very seriously particularly
after this
um but it is just just very sad that
this is the level of political debate
that we're having adam what do you think
about that i mean as a floridian
yourself you hear kind of like that
taking place from somebody who's going
up against uh
uh desantis and by the way this is
somebody that's pro
uh a concealed weapon like she's okay
with you so she's got some interesting
beliefs first woman to be elected as a
florida commissioner of agriculture
pro-concealed carry and pro-medical
marijuana referred to governor desantis
as hitler obviously only democrat to win
a statewide office in 2018 elections one
of 17 speakers to jointly deliver
keynote as democratic national
commission the dnc graduated from
university florida masters in political
campaigning supports voting rights for
felons excluding murderers and sex
offenders what do you think about when
you hear somebody like this make a
comment like this i don't know much
about nicki freed i think she did
graduate from university of florida and
she's a few years older than us but
here's what i'll say about the hitler
thing uh and full disclosure i had i'm
jewish i had my grandparents family
cousins they died in
in nazi germany you said it trivializes
exactly what he did now
it does one of two things for me at
least any person with common sense i'm
not even talking republican democrat
just common sense is gonna look at this
and be like what the are you talking
about here like do you understand how
stupid this makes you look
and just like because ron desantis might
have more conservative values he's now
he's [ __ ] hitler what are we talking
about here um but then
so anyone with common sense is just like
whatever but then there's gonna be
people
who listen to this
and maybe don't follow the news or
follow media and they're like no
he's he's he's a hitler yeah and and
they go down this rabbit hole of just
absurdity and the nest begins to pick up
fodder so we've seen it happen like
people used to say like
you know what george bush he's he's kind
of like hitler oh that's mitt romney you
guys you know he's like a hitler
trump you know and just like
okay enough's enough with the hitler
thing so for you as the press secretary
your job is to defend ron desantis are
there certain things that you're just
like listen i just like just
this is [ __ ] this is i don't want to
say that word but like this is so absurd
that i don't even want to answer this or
is it like no it's my job i actually
have to rebuttal such a ridiculous
comment how does that work i mean that's
how i see it it is my job but it really
depends on the source right so if it's
just a random person tweeting some
nonsense about the governor i'm not
gonna elevate it or give it attention
right but if it's a statewide official
which nikki fried is or if it's a major
media outlet like the associated press
you know no matter how absurd or
ridiculous the line of attack is i do
have to address it i mean that is my job
unfortunately you know i like i said i
wish we were talking more about
substantive issues versus this kind of
crazy rhetoric but you know she brought
it to that point so
we had to respond and i think like i
said there are a lot of folks like you
in florida who have relatives who have
ancestors who actually experienced these
crimes in nazi germany who were victims
of hitler and so to be talking like this
for her it's just it's it's really
inappropriate and who is she in the
context of the state of florida
what does she do exactly so she's the
agriculture commissioner but that's a
really big position in florida it not
only includes agriculture which we're a
big agricultural state but also it
includes issuing permits for concealed
carried weapons it includes um consumer
services so like reports of fraud her
office handles a lot of stuff related to
that so it's a pretty big position
unfortunately though you know
since she's been elected she's been
campaigning for governor basically she's
been using her office instead of
actually doing her job to help
agriculture thrive and to issue these
permits she is
just tweeting about governor desantis
all day well she's attacking you know
the guy at the job who in your mind is
the most likely candidate or candidates
to face off with ron desantis in
uh november well charlie crist is he
running again because right now you're
looking at some of the polls the reason
why we brought her up she just passed up
charlie cruz oh did she yeah i mean
fundraising a lot of uh post has her
ahead of him some have him over her but
uh
what is really the biggest difference
between him or charlie crist
i mean charlie crist was governor
already
and he was a republican when he was
governor and the but then he turned and
he became a senator and yeah he's a
he's as swampy as it gets in florida
right he's been back forth left right up
down yeah governor senator you know he's
been independent republican democrat and
so i think that's the big difference i
mean that he is
so nikki is younger she's always been a
democrat you know maybe some democrats
would trust her more because of that um
that she hasn't been a party switcher
charlie crist has been all over the
place i think what's really offensive
about charlie chris i mean there's many
things but one is in 2019 he visited
communist cuba took pictures with the
communist regime there like with
officials there and that was online as
basically pro-government propaganda
websites in cuba are showing this as
though charlie crist supports them and i
know he was well he said that he was
just trying to
build the diplomatic relationship um
there are a lot of cuban americans in
florida so he thought you know this
would be a good idea but i think it's
it's very offensive because the cuban
americans here they escape from that for
a reason and they don't want to like see
an american politician who wants to
represent them legitimizing this regime
who's the civil regime but who sits
there and tells you it's a good idea to
do that
and by the way you're representing
florida like i'm curious you know who
the marketing person and says hey
charlie we should go to florida and say
you know we should go to cuba cuba and
take a picture what are you thinking i
mean look i'm glad i'm not his press
secretary because i could not make
excuses for that i could not spin that i
mean that's just sickening and governor
desantis has always been you know a huge
supporter of freedom in cuba and that's
why i think you know he does have a lot
of support among that community and they
can see he's not a dictator so these
comparisons like like chris actually
after nicki free compared to hitler
chris hit back he's actually more like
castro so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye
[Music]